[Musica]
da circa 20 anni mi occupo di
progettazione di biblioteche di luoghi
per la cultura
ho iniziato a occuparmi di biblioteca di
progettare biblioteche all'università e
progettare biblioteche mi ha subito ma
subito appassionato poi nel 95 prima di
laurearmi aveva 23 anni con altri
colleghi ho aperto una società di
progettazione ho iniziato a occuparmi di
questi temi anche a livello come dire
professionale occuparmene nella realtà
no nel 2001 è uscito un concorso un
concorso un concorso internazionale
molto importante a milano per la famosa
immagino che molti di voi la sappiano di
cosa parlo
biblioteca europea di informazione e
cultura sarebbe stata la più grande
biblioteca pubblica italiana è una delle
più grande in europa
e allora era uscito questo concorso è
mandai una mail un architetto che
chiamiamo che mi piaceva molto peter
wilson che aveva studio a mister io in
un interrail l'anno prima era andato a
vedere una biblioteca che lui aveva
progettato che ha realizzato a mestre
ancora adesso secondo me una delle
biblioteche più interessanti costruito
negli ultimi 40 anni e gli stessi questa
mail dicendogli siamo un giovane studio
eccetera è uscito questo concorso perché
non lo facciamo insieme questo concorso
l'abbiamo vinto abbiamo sviluppato
elaborato tutto il progetto preliminare
definitivo esecutivo il progetto è stato
anche approvato dal consiglio superiore
lavori pubblici e poi è rimasta sulla
carta
come tanti progetti in italia ed è stato
un gran peccato non solo ovviamente per
noi ma secondo me anche per milano
perché per milano
diciamo per anche per il nostro paese
perché comunque probabilmente questa
biblioteca questo che è molto più di una
biblioteca sarebbe potuta essere per
milano quello che il borgo è stato per
parigi negli anni 80 era una biblioteca
enorme 60mila metri quadri tremila posti
a sedere e 500 mila volumi a scaffale
aperto oltre 3 milioni volumi a deposito
c'erano tante cose dentro però va bene è
rimasta sulla carta peccato però
comunque di progettare biblioteche non
ho più smesso
e ne ho progettato tante costruite anche
diverse mi sono occupato di però di
questi temi non soltanto a livello di
progettazione architettonica degli
arredi degli interni d'accordo ma anche
a livello di progettazione funzionale
perché l'architettura dell'edificio
l'architettura del servizio sono le più
facili una stessa medaglia sono
fondamentali entrambe e quindi
elaborando linee guida programmi
funzionali studi di fattibilità persino
in alcuni casi progettazione dei servizi
è quello di cui vi parlo
voglio parlare adesso è proprio questo
cioè ho cercato di elaborare anche
livello teorico scrivendo neanche tanto
un nuovo modello per così dire qua non
c'è una ricetta precisa non c'è una
ricetta univoca e attenzione però
diciamo un nuovo modello verso un nuovo
modello di biblioteca di biblioteca
pubblica per da declinare ovviamente
calata nella realtà italiana ma però
facciamo un passo indietro ma servono
ancora le biblioteche oggi che
biblioteche pubbliche attenzione parlo
in questo caso solo di biblioteche
pubbliche non parlo di vedute che
universitari non parlo di biblioteche di
conservazione perché tanto c'è tutto su
internet non c'è tutto su google
e allora diciamola la funzione primaria
che la biblioteca ha sempre avuto è
quella di centro di diffusione
trasferimento della conoscenza di
promozione della lettura di supporto
alla formazione del senso più ampio del
termine
e le nuove tecnologie non inficiano
questa funzione che resta fondamentale
anzi la amplificano all'ennesima potenza
possiamo dire perché la biblioteca e
oggi diventano le minute che pubbliche
in particolare a mio avviso centri
laboratori di informazione sport e di
accesso e strumenti di orientamento nel
dell'universo multimediale contro il
divario digitale tra coloro che in vario
modo hanno accesso agli strumenti e
soprattutto al know how non del del
mondo dell'informazione digitale coloro
che per varie ragioni ne sono tagliati
fuori
ma il problema del divario digitale si
sta ulteriormente complicando perché
sempre più gente accesso a internet
attraverso chiaramente gli smartphone ma
come abbiamo sentito anche stasera ne fa
un uso pessimo non si sa a districare
tra le fake news
non si sa a rientrare nei meandri della
cosiddetta amministrazione digitale e in
tutto questo le biblioteche pubbliche
possono essere in prima linea ma non per
smascherare le feci news non è questo
loro compito ma per fornire alle persone
gli strumenti per capire l'attendibilità
delle fonti e chi altro d'altronde può
dare questi strumenti a persone che sono
ormai uscite da qualsiasi come dire
circuito di formazione scolastica oppure
le persone anziane
la terza funzione a mio avviso persino
più importante che le biblioteche
pubbliche oggi possono devono avere e
quella di luogo di aggregazione sociale
piazze urbane nuove piazze urbane per
incontrarsi per comunicare per
consolidare il senso di appartenenza a
una comunità a una collettività contro
l'esclusione contro l'isolamento perché
nessuno rimanga indietro
e allora la biblioteca la biblioteca
pubblica è uno degli ultimi luoghi
realmente pubblici rimasti un luogo in
cui possono incontrarsi conoscersi anche
pagare per caso persone completamente
diverse tra loro per età per formazione
per provenienza per ceto sociale
soprattutto oggi che centri commerciali
centri polifunzionali e no di
intrattenimento sono i principali centri
di aggregazione soprattutto per il per i
giovani e soprattutto la biblioteche
pubbliche sono particolarmente preziose
perché hanno due caratteristiche che
altri luoghi non hanno
sono luoghi sicuri e sono luoghi
neutrali non è utili neutrale molto
diverso uno dei pochissimi luoghi
pubblici rimasti dove la dimensione
individuale quella collettiva si possono
come dire incontrare libera dal
condizionamento dell'ossessione
all'acquisto della confusione
all'acquisto dell'ossessione al consumo
e allora certo che le biblioteche
pubbliche sono fondamentali ancora oggi
anzi le biblioteche pubbliche sono le
pietre angolari di una società
democratica sana e vivace sono strumenti
per consolidare il capitale sociale di
una di una comunità strumenti di
coesione e di inclusione sociale
però dobbiamo capire di che biblioteca
stiamo parlando perché per rilanciare il
suo ruolo come ve lo sto raccontando a
mio avviso la biblioteca pubblica deve
cambiare in alcuni casi radicalmente sia
come servizi che come spazi le
biblioteche devono passare dall'essere
luoghi di conservazione all'essere
luoghi di conversazione un piccolo una
grama un gioco di parole ovviamente ma è
una rivoluzione in alcuni casi
copernicana biblioteche come luoghi del
dialogo lo di chi in contaminazione
perché oggi per le biblioteche pubbliche
e più importante essere luoghi di
connessioni che luoghi di collezioni
così o almeno le biblioteche pubbliche
dovrebbero essere invece moltissime
biblioteche italiane sono ancora oggi
sostanzialmente sale studio e magazzini
di prestito libri e hanno una in media
un indice di impatto tra il 5 per cento
e il 10 per cento che dice di impatto è
la percentuale di popolazione locale che
frequenta la biblioteca sostanzialmente
noi in modo abituale allora cui siamo a
reggio emilia le biblioteche del sistema
bibliotecario legge emilia superano
anche il 20 per cento di ingegneri il
patto
in provincia si sono biblioteche che
sono delle come dire assolutamente delle
punte di diamante non conosco ad albinea
conosco cavriago il multiplo che arriva
anche supera il 40 per cento e lecce
sono eccezioni non è la regola italiana
arrigo l'italiano è molto diversa regola
italiana e lo zero virgola talvolta o
ripeto quando si arriva al 15 al 20 per
cento
bisogna brindare e festeggiare nord
europa si supera il 40 e il 50 e il 60
per cento dice di indice di impatto ma
però voglio fare un po il ragionamento
inverso non fare un pò l'avvocato del
diavolo ma se la mia biblioteca è
sostanzialmente soltanto una sala studio
magazzino di libri magari collocate in
un edificio brutto scomodo che chiuso
nel mio tempo libero ma perché mai
dovrei andarci a meno che non ha
l'urgenza di prendere questi un libro
che non vogliono non posso comprare e
che poi magari faccio fatica a
restituire perché non c'è l'autore
istituzione no way la biblioteca chiusa
e allora capite bene che un circolo
vizioso allora capite bene che le
biblioteche vanno completamente
ripensate le biblioteche devono
diventare dei luoghi molteplici qui
avvengono tante cose in cui d'accordo
sono pozzo ne continuano e continueranno
ad essere piene di libri e di e di film
e di musica e di internet e di wifi
gratuito ed i giornali riviste però
anche di tantissime attività concerti
presentazioni dei libri gruppi di
lettura corsi di formazione corsi per il
tempo libero di ogni genere tutta una
serie di attività culturali spazi fluidi
dove tablet e libri convivono senza
soluzione di continuità dove incontra
anche un posto bello dove comprarsi a
prendere un caffè con gli amici in un
luogo però che è ricco di stimoli
stimoli culturali evidentemente no
luoghi in cui avvengono tante cose
contemporaneamente servizi che offrono
servizi per la cultura la formazione
l'informazione il tempo libero la
creatività l'immaginazione non solo lo
studio catalizzatori urbani di
promozione di attività e politiche
culturali catalizzatore a in chimica una
sostanza reagente è qualcosa che è in
grado di attivare un processo no e
allora
perché non ho citato i libri la
promozione della lettura
ma perché la situazione è questa in
italia il 60 per cento della popolazione
italiana secondo tutte le statistiche
correnti consolidate da più di dieci
anni legge meno di un libro l'anno circa
il 9 per cento legge più di 5 libri
l'anno solo il 9 per cento
e allora se io vado a combinare queste
statistiche mi rendo conto che se io
progetto realizzo gestisco una
biblioteca che è focalizzata soltanto su
promozione del libro e della lettura mi
rivolgerò a stento al 20 per cento della
popolazione come utenza potenziale e
allora forse sto sbagliando perché
l'ottanta per cento restante a cui io mi
devo rivolgere quello che ha
maggiormente forse bisogno delle
biblioteche non posso delegare i centri
commerciali la delega per l'appunto di
occuparmi del tempo libero di una fetta
così ampia della popolazione
e allora bisogna anche ragionare su
altro bisogna ragionare sui luoghi sulla
bellezza di un luogo nel momento di
massima diffusione dei social network le
biblioteche devono puntare su quell
unica cosa che google facebook amazon
avranno mai la fisicità di un bel posto
dove andare dove incontri bibliotecario
che mi sorride e mi orienta nelle mie
ricerche dove incontrò amici veri sono
il contraltare dei miei amici virtuali
ed è qualcosa che all'estero hanno
capito molto bene non è un caso se
all'estero al progressivo calo degli
indici di presto libri che generalizzato
in tutte le biblioteche europee non
corrisponde un calo degli indici di
frequentazione delle biblioteche perché
le biblioteche sono dei bei posti e
questo proprio un bel posto dove andare
e stato lo slogan che noi avevamo
coniato un progetto abbiamo fatto
qualche anno fa la mediateca di meda che
abbiamo inaugurato nel 2012 e che ancora
oggi a distanza di sette anni
afa 700 mila visite al giorno siamo
vicino monza brianza e questo era
proprio era un luogo come dire un luogo
bello piacevole attraente pieno di come
dire di attività per grandi per bambini
per i piccoli per gli anziani in cui
succedono tante cose
questo è emerso un altra biblioteca me
da 2 mila metri quadri anche questa
circa duemila metri quadri ha sempre
vicino a milano e anche questo è pensata
come uno spazio accogliente flessibile
con tanti tanti piccoli ampie tanti
ambienti differenti tra loro no non solo
una grande
la sala di lettura non solo un magazzino
di libri che ognuno può trovare delle
cose questa e comano 800 metri quadri
comano terme vicino trento l'aveva
inaugurata due mesi fa e anche qui spazi
accoglienti informali flessibili
luminosi colorati dove si suona anche il
pianoforte perché no dove anche lo
spazio per i bambini è pensato tutti gli
spazi di rimini sono tutti diversi
non vado a ripetere sempre stessa
soluzione comunque ancora più piccola e
morbegno e tirano 500 circa 500 metri
quadri e dove vedete che la stessa idea
di informalità di flessibilità viene
declinata anche in spazi più piccoli
qui ancora più piccolo 320 metri quadri
caspoggio provincia di soldi questo è il
primo evidentemente è questo il dopo ma
non è che abbiamo soltanto abbattuto due
tramezzi interni messo due come dire
scaffali colorati qualche lampada carina
che è fondamentale tutto questo
ovviamente qui è stata ripensata anche
la radicalmente l'organizzazione
funzionale ripensando la biblioteca come
spazio flessibile accogliente dove
ciascuno trova qualcosa di bello a fare
chi gioca a carte chi studia chi legge
che legge un libro è qualcosa di bello
anche per i più piccoli e allora non è
però comunque abbastanza concludo come
dire focalizzando cinque concetti chiave
che a mio avviso devono informare
qualsiasi progetto di biblioteca
pubblica che si che volesse realmente
efficace il primo essere indie pt le
biblioteche come luoghi di idee ed
ispirazione luoghi di narrazione di
combinazione di interpretazione che mi
portano a trovare quello che non sapevo
di stare cercando che mi portano a
trovare qualcosa sempre di bello di
inaspettato di emozionante che mi spinge
a come dire abbattere un pregiudizio a
cambiare idea sulle cose attraverso i
libri
ovviamente ma anche attraverso
l'attività che ci sono dentro e
biblioteche come luogo di apprendimento
ovviamente luogo di scoperta di
formazione di alfabetizzazione
attraverso corsi conferenze laboratori
spazi per lo studio spazi per lo studio
di gruppo fondamentali sempre più
importanti servizi di e learning
biblioteche come luoghi di persone
luoghi di incontro di socializzazione di
partecipazione
la biblioteca come nelle minute che devo
trovare degli spazi belli
e rilassanti dove posso anche a come
dicevo prima a prendere un caffè con gli
amici ma le biblioteche possono anche
essere delle nuove agorà luoghi di
cittadinanza attiva di partecipazione le
biblioteche come luogo di esperienza
luogo esperienziale luogo di co
creazione interazione coinvolgimento
dove l'utente non è soltanto un fruitore
passivo ma può essere anche un utente
cioè un protagonista attivo che mette a
disposizione magari suoi talenti le sue
competenze perché no e poi anche le
biblioteche come laboratori laboratori
per fare esperienze di tante cose
diverse e laboratori digitali dove
sperimenta nuovi strumenti nuove app
realtà virtuale realtà aumentata oppure
anche laboratori di riscoperta delle
tecniche artigianali e attenzione nelle
immagini che vi sto mostrando non ci
sono soltanto colonia helsinki
copenaghen horus eccetera ci sono
cavriago qui vicino reggio emilia c'è
pistoia la san giorgio di pistoia cessa
la borsa c'è paderno dugnano e cinisello
balsamo quindi non è che dobbiamo
necessariamente andare in nord europa
per vedere delle belle del dl delle
buone pratiche e infine le biblioteche
come luogo di creatività incentrate
sull'innovazione sulla sperimentazione e
soprattutto sul gioco e allora le
biblioteche si riempiono di è che il
caffè fab lab maker space coder dojo
tutta una serie di neologismi che
indicano attività anche molto diverse
tra loro che hanno a che fare alcune
analogiche alcune digitali ma che tutta
una che fare con l'innovazione con il
gioco nelle biblioteche per esempio si
riempie di maker space dove trovo
stampanti 3d taglia e cuci macchine da
cucire termo presse botton makers ma per
che cosa hanno a che fare queste cose le
biblioteche perché la biblioteca è un
luogo dove posso anche imparare a fare
delle cose perché la distinzione tra ciò
che riguarda i libri e ciò che non lo
riguarda i sempre più come dire
evanescente sempre meno almeno rilevante
e sempre meno lo sarà biblioteche dove
posso andare anche andare a fare video
maker registrare suonare musica e allora
la biblioteca come spazio flessibile
modificabile non gerarchico uno spazio
di libertà uno spazio per
l'immaginazione ricco di contenuti e in
grado di evolvere ma soprattutto come vi
dicevo un bel posto dove andare
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]